here's the tax you have to do get a
credit card One credit card okay spend
about $50 a month on it you don't need
to spend any more than that and then pay
it off make sure you pay it off on time
every month month after month the
algorithms that look at you increase
your credit score regardless of how much
you're paying off so you don't have to
put thousands on it the fact that you
pay it off gets you a higher score
immediately this is the trick you have
to do it's a hack that's what I call it
right out of college get a card don't
abuse it pay it off every month any
small amount Works Bingo you get a new
credit card another great vampire tip